and we begin this morning with President
Trump calling on the FBI to launch an
investigation into his Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh the
investigation into sexual assault
allegations against Cavanaugh came at
the request of Arizona Republican
Senator Jeff Flake a key vote in the
confirmation the panel passed
Cavanaugh's nomination out of committee
Friday but agreed to Flakes request to
delay a final vote on the nomination to
allow time for an investigation last
night the president tweeted our 7th
investigation of Judge Brett Kavanaugh
he will someday be recognized as a truly
great Justice of the United States
Supreme Court errol barnett is at the
White House Erol good morning good
morning look this is a troubling moment
for the White House asking the FBI to
investigate is a reversal for President
Trump who repeatedly said judge Brett
Kavanaugh had already been sufficiently
vetted the president's saying in a
statement though this investigation will
be limited in scope and lasts only one
week I will be totally reliant on what
Senator Grassley and the group decides
to do president Trump is deferring to
Senate leadership on how to best proceed
with the confirmation vote for his
embattled Supreme Court nominee judge
Brett Kavanaugh
the president also said dr. Christine
Blasi Ford was quote a very credible
witness when she testified before the
Senate Judiciary Committee Thursday
alleging Cavanaugh drunkenly pinned her
to a bed and groped her when they were
teenagers indelible in the hippocampus
is the laughter the lap the uproarious
laughter between the two and they're
having fun at my expense
I am innocent of this charge but
President Trump also praised the
testimony of Cavanaugh I thought that
that's testimony likewise was really
something that I haven't seen before it
was incredible Democrats are now getting
their demand for the FBI to look into
allegations of Cavanaugh's alleged
sexual misconduct which may include
interviews with additional witnesses I
think to ask for a week is not to ask
for too much
Friday Ford's lawyer said she welcomes
this step in the process and Judge
Cavanaugh said in a statement he will
continue to cooperate with the Senate
divided it took just one Republican
holdout to get what Democrats had been
asking for Arizona's Jeff Flake who is
not seeking re-election made a critical
decision that's my position this
country's being ripped apart here and
and we've got to make sure that we do
doing due diligence Flake said he would
not vote to confirm Cavanaugh without a
week-long FBI probe first the senator
initially announced he would vote for
Kavanagh but that decision enraged
sexual assault victims who blocked the
door of his elevator leading to this
encounter
annamaria archila was one of those
protesters we kept the door open so that
he would be forced to examine his
actions and and think about the
consequences for the women that are
watching now the White House will set
parameters for the investigation
including whether agents can speak to
two other women also accusing judge
Kavanaugh of sexual misconduct it's also
unclear if agents will interview mark
judge the Aletta witness to the alleged
Ford assault a lawyer for judge says he
will cooperate with the FBI
Anthony Errol Barnett at the White House
thanks Errol